doing this
okay
see if it is
all right
tell me when it comes up
okay i don't see okay yeah i got it okay
all right let's go
all right we'll wait for more people to
show up
and they'll start coming over here
man
okay they're kind of starting to come in
sorry about that finish the story
i didn't even remember where that story
was i didn't even remember we were
talking i had to go to the bathroom in
between yeah
they're all coming in
yeah we just lost and i don't know like
when it uh when it stopped
yeah
because what were we taught what was
what was she talking about well i was
talking about my well we were talking
about your dad yeah and i was talking
about my grandma
and then i was saying that
you never know like uh when the last
time you're gonna see a person is
because we were talking about our friend
kaylee
who um you know we talked about this on
our pre-halloween show
recently sadly passed away of cancer and
she was only 34.
um
we knew it was coming
but because she'd been sick a while but
man that was still like really [ __ ] up
and like so young like that so i kind of
feel like
i don't know i kind of feel like
honestly you never know when the last
time you're gonna see somebody is
because you don't know they could be
like [ __ ] 20 and they get hit by a
bus
you know like a day after you see them
that's what life is though i know but
uh
well the fact that that's the way life
is i think that's like more uh
ammunition in my thing it's like well
just treat people
like that's the last time you're ever
gonna see them like don't be a dick to
them yeah because you don't know they
could get hit by a bus like five minutes
after you see them and then you'll feel
really bad
so
don't be a douche
i mean unless somebody's being a douche
to you we almost drink half this bottle
that's okay
it's friday night [ __ ] yeah
i drove all the way to lakers i left the
house today yeah he does something she
left the house
i haven't left the house and like [ __ ] i
don't even remember the last time i left
the house trying to get your ass to
[ __ ] go out at least for a walk
well i like my bike though [ __ ] crazy
there's no uh sidewalks in this
neighborhood yeah but they all walk down
the street i see people walking every
[ __ ] morning there's no traffic out
there
these are private roads
oh look it went red on us
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this [ __ ] i
don't know i'm gonna try to take this
yeah you broke it i broke it
i'm gonna blame you why shouldn't i i'm
gonna lower that pitcher quality down
yeah what do you think if i don't know
why it's doing that
yeah you turned your xbox off
yeah no need for me css jenny i'm so
sorry for your loss yeah one minute
they're here and then not
it's just kind of like and it always
you always think it's not gonna hit you
because like my grandma
um
this was my dad's mom
and she kind of helped raising us
so
i was really really close to her and
like the few years before she died
i had bought a house only like a mile
away from her so like you know a couple
times a week i would like walk down this
you know a mile down the street and i'd
go and hang out with her for the day
we'd watch like dumbass we'd watch like
[ __ ] a haunting or whatever was on
and we'd watch it and just like kind of
hang out or whatever
and um
you know i knew she was sick i knew she
had stomach cancer and i knew that after
a while she was just kind of like look
i'm in too much pain i don't really want
to you know prolong this or whatever
and i got that and she got sent to
hospice but i didn't realize how fast it
was gonna happen so i kind of feel like
you know i was there with her one night
she was still awake and then i had to go
to work
and then i said oh it'll be fine i'll be
back
you know the next morning or the next
day and the next day i was back and she
was in a coma
and um then she died and i didn't really
get to say goodbye and that kind of
bummed me out
so
yeah you know
it just bummed me out so you really have
to kind of
you know
just kind of treat the if you don't see
people that often you have to like kind
of
act like this is the last time you're
going to see them don't be a douche um
you know
i don't say you have to like kind of
[ __ ] climb all over them and like you
know bless them or anything but just
i'm just saying it's like
you know
just don't be a dick that's all
all right it looks like everybody's kind
of showing back up
yeah i don't really know what
happened there
well it's
i have to say the connection out here is
very intermittent yeah
it's not bad it's not terrible but
you can't really trust it you can't rely
on it so long period of time no so after
a while i'm always kind of like having
stress and anxiety about it because i'm
like oh my god this seems like it's
gonna like [ __ ] go tits up in a
minute yeah so you know what i mean
jenny's being introspective yeah what
else is new
jenny's always introspective that's kind
of like my whole thing
that's kind of my whole thing
um
strong 78 says i don't believe in good
karma or bad karma it's just karma
yeah i mean i guess karma is just kind
of like
um
the whole definition of karma
is
we're gonna uh
get back at you for whatever good or bad
you did so if you're a good person
probably shouldn't worry about it if
you're a bad person maybe you should
worry about it although if you're a bad
person you probably don't worry about it
although maybe you should
but the people that should worry about
it
don't which is
that's man that's the shitty thing of
the human condition the people that
really need to like feel guilty about
bad behavior are the people that don't
feel guilty about bad behavior
that bums me out so much but yeah
um you know so
uh yeah it's up to that other
food dish out there runs to it points at
it and looks at me you got a bunch of
treats there she's like i don't want
more she thinks that it's not enough she
thinks that she doesn't have a big
enough supply see but she's got a hole
but you got a whole point right there
this is what you have a whole plate
right there
that's cookout that's like your favorite
yeah she wants multiple feeding dishes
out
with different
temptation flavors in each one of them
she knows exactly what each flavor is
she'll go up to the green one and go
this one i want the green one yeah
that's the catnip yeah yeah i want the
red one and the red one which is cookout
which is kind of like liver or beet
that's liver and beef right she knows
what all those tastes like by the yellow
one's chicken and she wants
a bunch of different flavors out at once
so she can have so she can pick just she
can pick and choose she's [ __ ] smart
man
and she doesn't eat them right away
she's just like okay we'll save them for
later yeah put that flavor there yeah
and put cause i have cookout right right
there on that dish yeah in the bedroom
what flavor is in there
chicken
or cabbage okay what's she doing she's
right there what are you doing
you know what i was trying to get her to
do the other day she's on the ground
okay
so elsa
sent her the halloween toys which she
loves by the way she has a little pile
of them over here she's a little dracula
like all the little mousies and stuff
she loves those she goes around like
plays them all the time
i was trying to get her
because other day she had like the
little
orange crinkly ball
and she like rolled over on her belly
and she was like playing with the
crinkly ball like she was laying on her
back and i was trying to get her like
take the other crinkly ball so it'd be
like pom-poms
i was like oh my god cheerleader and i
was going to take a picture but she
would not do it no no
she had the little like orange oh and
she's like and she threw it over there
and she's just like
why are you taking a picture of me she
was like really suspicious tina says
pookie spoiled you don't have any idea
taylor i'll be in the bed okay
she says fall asleep with my [ __ ]
earbud in listening to some other
podcaster i'll fall asleep i'll wake up
and i'll step my earbud in and i'll roll
over and i'll look at jenny and jenny's
on her side and [ __ ] pookie is
standing on my shoulders well
i can't sleep with pookie's standing on
the shoulder
she's yelled at me she's still asleep
what is this this cannot stand yeah and
i mean get off there
get off here it just looks at me like no
although like i said i'm usually a
wicket
because honestly
pookie is she's very small she only
weighs what couple pounds 10 11 pounds
maybe yeah
but
i mean i'm sleeping and as soon as i
feel this little pause on the end of the
bed
and i'm just like oh and that wakes me
up and then she she has a thing where
it's like she steps on my shins
she crawls up your whole body yeah
so there's like little 10 11 pounds like
climbing up your leg
climbing up your butt climbing up your
back yeah and then if you're because
kind of i sleep on my side or kind of on
my you know on my stomach and then
she'll come up on the shoulder and be
like
are you awake yeah
big black eyes yes you wake up you still
asleep and then she starts making
biscuits yeah on your shoulder
yeah i'll feel something on my [ __ ]
back shoulder and i'll turn around and
look like
look she's back and going
one thing she's been doing lately is
that she'll put her her back feet will
be on my hip
and then her front feet will be making
biscuits on your side yeah yeah
she's funny man
she doesn't do it all night because a
lot of times she'll sleep on her own
she's pretty good about like being on
her own but
man every now and then she'd be like oh
i'm kind of lonely what are those
[ __ ] doing and then she'll like climb
up on the bed and be like love me yeah
please love me
and i can't be mad because she's too
[ __ ] she just wants to know why we're
still asleep
when you guys getting up
what's that book
tina's yeah saying something about her
what'd she say
uh all three furry boys wake up the hubs
in the morning at 5 30 a.m for feeding
and outside time yeah they yell or roar
for him to get about 5 30. that's what
she pookie does the same thing um yeah
pookie does it like usually before day
break
yeah before the sun comes up i mean i
usually wake up
between i mean gotta be honest
i usually wake up between 3 and 4 30
because i have to pee
uh i can't sleep whole night without
having to get up and pee which sucks but
i don't understand it
between 3 and 4 30 i will usually wake
up to go to the bathroom
and so if i do that
um sometimes i'll see pookie she'll be
sitting in the hall
and i'll be like hey poke what's up and
she's like
she's awake
and then i go back and get in bed and
try to go back to sleep yeah that's not
happening she's asking if poopy snores
no she doesn't snore and she doesn't
really purr very loud either she purrs
but it's not like you have to get right
up on her to hear it you gotta touch her
to know she's purr you'll feel it but
she's she's real quiet another thing she
doesn't do she doesn't really
meow well she kind of does she mostly
does
she goes
yeah
she makes like a trolling sound yeah
and uh
i think it's come here yeah she runs
like
yeah yeah well she's running yeah
sometimes she'll meow but it depends
i think i told you guys like on the
wednesday show
she's become convinced that the absinthe
poster i have over there like the lucid
absence poster that has a black cat on
it that that's a real cat i think she
thinks that's a real cat yeah
um and she think she's like trying to
free it
from what she thinks is a window because
she's
uh for the past week or so she's been
trying to pull that
picture off the wall like she gets up
there with her paw and like tries to
like pull it and she's like talking to
it
and she's like pulling it
i don't know like some of it might be
she likes that sink she likes to drink
water at the sink
so sometimes she jumps up on the [ __ ]
and she's just kind of like
looks at me and she's like and i'm like
oh okay you want water
she's got a fountain but
she likes to drink out of the sink for
whatever reason okay so we got about
half the audience back we're down at
about 15.
we had about 45 in there before i don't
know what happened to when they probably
fell asleep while we were talking
uh what time is it right now
8 30. 8 30 8 30 40 yeah
okay yeah pookie doesn't really she
doesn't snore she doesn't um
i don't know she doesn't really snore
no
she's not real noisy she's kind of she's
talkative but not like she doesn't yell
or anything like that but it's mostly
like
she's like grumbly yeah it makes little
grumbling noises i call her grumbly yeah
because she just like she comes in and
she's just like
she makes some noises like that yeah i
think she tries to talk
yeah she's trying to talk yeah
maybe because she didn't grow up around
other cats other than beijing
and she's grouper
and beijing doesn't make a lot of noise
either
so i think she's trying to mimic
human noises yeah and laughter
i think the
is khmer and it's also kind of like a
laughter i think
man you should have seen it this morning
yeah she did that like she was down by
the bedroom that door
what are you trying what are you trying
to open the cabinet door oh yeah
there's nothing in there babe
she's looking at me going
but
yeah she came down the hall earlier she
was by the bedroom and i was down here
but in this bathroom
and she saw me like in the door and she
was like
and she like runs down the [ __ ] hall
and i'm just like what is it oh my
goodness it sounded like super important
but you know
i don't know what she's trying to say
she's trying to get into the
you trying to get in the cabinet pool
okay it's like i said before it's open
lines friday if you guys have any
subjects you want to talk about or any
questions you can go ahead and ask now
and uh we'll we'll [ __ ] talk about
that too if not it's just going to be me
and jen sitting here trying to come up
with something to talk about
bust out the matthias wig tom no no wigs
right now no wigs oh come on too [ __ ]
hot man
i'm too i've been drinking too much guys
which
wait a minute which one is that
which one was the matthias wig that was
like mathias like the [ __ ] like about
the white wig
i thought it was like the white wig yeah
trying to go trying to get me to go back
and [ __ ] the vanilla gorilla [ __ ]
mode vanilla gorilla
with the white wig
monkey the honky car oh my god how do
you [ __ ] people i'm gonna call you
that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
vanilla vanilla gorilla
[Laughter]
you know what makes me happy about that
though
is that
dorks nowadays geeks nowadays that came
up with that term they still remember
one
donkey
and the fact that enough people remember
that
because that's like some [ __ ]
man i i barely remember that [ __ ] that
was like my childhood that was my
childhood yeah so that's like super
funny that's the only ones i can come up
with
startup 78 what do you think of people
who wanted to cancel kubrick because of
how he tortured shelley duvall in the
shining
um [ __ ] honestly stanley kubrick is
dead so i'm pretty sure no one can
cancel them at this point
i kind of feel like the whole cancel
culture thing is just uh
that's just some dumb [ __ ] that you know
everybody wants to get outraged about
stuff just like shut up about it i'm
like kind of bored of it but
um
i'm not gonna justify uh how
kubrick or any director
tortures their actors
um
you know because a lot of that shit's
like unforgivable
but
you can kind of justify it a little bit
from an artistic point of view if the
movie comes out good if the movie comes
out shitty
then cancel them all you want well we
also don't know how accurate that story
is because there's also a lot of stories
made up to help bolster the reputation
of a movie and a producer
may have not been anywhere near as bad
as what you're both what what
what people are thinking
and well i wasn't there so i don't
really know deval probably knew exactly
what what was going on she was just a
method actor going through it you know
just so yeah yeah yeah i mean kubrick
was kind of known for
not being super um
it wasn't real friendly with people well
he wanted what he wanted
and i kind of feel like his whole thing
was he had a vision
uh the actors were just kind of like
obstacles in the way of getting to that
vision so he's kind of like i'm just
gonna like
put you in a place where and don't do
like human [ __ ] because i want this that
and the other thing so i understand
that that might not like you know some
of his movies he didn't even talk to the
actors he had somebody else talk to him
for him
like in 2001 he was evidently pretty
separate from the actress he would have
other people give the directions to the
actors for him that's kind of weird but
you don't know that might have been
insecurity too it may be that he wasn't
real
secure around actors so he has somebody
else
relaying towards him well
and honestly like
um i get that
i get uh where kubrick is coming from
and it's not and i kind of feel like
people that don't know
people that are like really like
introverted
um
maybe you know like maybe to you that
comes across as like rude or you're
being but
it's a thing where you don't really want
to like [ __ ] interact with people
because
you don't want to interact with people
because you feel like they're gonna like
not
like look i don't i don't feel like i'm
good enough to talk to you or i feel
like you're gonna like
come at me or shine this thing and yeah
it's it's more an introversion thing
than a rudeness thing
so you have to really be careful with
that kind of [ __ ] because a lot of
creative people
um are very introverted
and if they have to interact with other
people in the sense of like making a
movie or something like that um
[Music]
it's not so much rudeness it's just that
i don't feel
they don't feel like they're good enough
to talk to you or
they don't think their shit's going to
come across the way that they want it to
come across so it's not
i don't know i i kind of feel like it's
more
i don't know it
she's going torture in what way well now
what it is is that evidently
the story goes
is that kubrick
um
would do everything he could to keep uh
what we kept picking on on
he was trying to get to make her act
like a performance out of yeah yeah make
her act like a battered woman who didn't
know what was happening and evidently he
would like it
kind of berate her and [ __ ] oh that's
not good you know and he would give her
conflicting orders to keep her
pent up and [ __ ]
because she she you know she looked
great on camera she looked [ __ ]
terrified
but
look man
the hollywood scene people make stuff up
to [ __ ]
bolster their their their their
they're legend so who knows
probably wasn't as serious as people
think it was
well i don't know if i'd say that
because they did
we were just talking about this on
exorcist 2.
uh and i was thinking about this when i
woke up at 4 00 a.m and couldn't go back
to sleep
i was thinking about the whole situation
this is this is what kept me awake last
night in case you were curious
uh the whole exorcist ii situation with
linda blair
having to stand at the edge of that
[ __ ] however many stories that
building was about 40.
and
no safety harnesses
no double
no nothing insane yeah
if i was linda blair to be like boop
i'm out it'd be huge lawsuits i quit
yeah i quit
nope no thank you yeah
i can't even watch that
and now that i know how they filmed it
because when i was watching it i was
like man that looks real that was
upsetting and then when i researched it
i'm like oh that was real i don't think
i can watch that anymore yeah if i watch
that again i'd probably throw
i was just kind of like
i have really really really
bad
acrophobia you guys really bad
you guys i went to new york city
i went to
the top of the empire state building
my ex-husband had to drag me
to he's like come on it's fine
drag me to the thing and there was like
[ __ ]
fence and everything like that and i had
to look over there and like
nope bye yeah and i went ran back to the
elevator
no thank you no thank you what's funny
is that looking down the side of a very
tall building he gets me even kind of
like whoa
you know
yeah oh i hate it yeah but i don't even
like thinking about it but i can ride in
a helicopter [ __ ] thousands of feet
off the ground with doors open looking
outside spitting spitting dip smoke a
cigarette throw it out you know not a
big deal
or or [ __ ] rappel out of a helicopter
there's something about
looking down the side of a building or
you're around solid objects you're not
hanging in space
you're around these solid objects and it
gives you the perspective
so you can actually
get that vertigo feeling
well you know you're not gonna fall out
maybe maybe that's what it is no i think
it's
no looking over the side of something is
kind of when there's a building
site when there's the buildings and
other things involved it gives you
you understand this your spatial
awareness is better yeah so you realize
how high you are yeah it magnifies it
but if you're just hanging in space or
hanging from the bottom of a helicopter
it's not quite it's not so yeah right i
guess because there's no the perspective
isn't there right so you can jump out
it's not even you know it's not even
hard because you know it it's just you
don't have that we don't have a sense of
scale you don't have the sense of scale
so you just gotta [ __ ] it i'm gonna come
outside a helicopter and then go out
swiss style
but could i do that from the top of a
40-story skyscraper
it'd have been a lot harder because
you're looking down and you're seeing
all those lines intersecting and you're
like oh
man
you know because it could happen to me
too you know i had to start spinning
man
honestly all i said and this is what
kept me awake after i came back to bed
at four in the morning
i was like man if linda blair had fallen
swicky's new awakening this is why i
can't sleep
if she had fallen what would they have
done like did they have any protocol
did they have anything was then somebody
like hanging on to like her clothes or
something this must have been something
they did at the [ __ ] they just did at
the trip they just did on in the moment
that upsets me like even more like
watching that movie because i thought
when we watched the movie i was like oh
my god that looks real and that's like
really upsetting but then when i found
out that it actually was real and she
there wasn't even like a [ __ ]
okay for one thing why did that building
not have
railings all the way around it's like oh
we're gonna have railings like part of
the way but then we're gonna have like
these [ __ ] open areas because fun
just in case you want to fall off you
can if you want to
you know
um
you know so i don't know why they did
that but
and then to have an actress
go right up to the edge of that like
that and just like kind of stand there
in a nightgown
and honestly like a stiff wind could
have come along and blown her off there
and then they'd be like oh god when now
what do we do
i don't think they had a harness on her
or anything
now tina says she remembers hiking the
half dome in yosemite [ __ ] that with her
husband and a girl started to cry
we had to hold and grab a piece of rock
the letter down i remember the half dome
goddamn i've been there
i'll tell you what taylor whenever i
think of yosemite or redwood forest what
really comes to mind is just the smell
of the way that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] beautiful [ __ ] smell of
pine
and
burning pine
from campfires
and just the [ __ ] smell of like
[ __ ] s'mores cooking
and the smell of [ __ ] fresh coffee
with that [ __ ] as a kid you know up in
the damn camper with me and [ __ ]
cousin wesley my aunt lois and [ __ ]
all the like friends of the ants and
then all those damn girls running around
it was just a good time man i always
liked i always liked [ __ ] sequoia
it's quite beautiful there's nothing
else like it i can't believe that's in
california
we need to bring that [ __ ] here to
florida that's what we need we need to
bring sequoia to florida
yeah starduck 78's are over the edge
yeah yeah and honestly
i'm watching that movie and i'm watching
that scene going
this does not look like
she was a young girl though so she you
know i mean young people are crazy you
can you can you they got yeah but she
didn't really want to do the movie we
talked about this [ __ ] on the matinee
show she didn't really want to do the
movie
uh other than one the original version
of the script was good which
spoiler alert is not what ended up
happening in the
you know finished movie
and also because richard burton was in
it yeah so i don't know she really
signed up with hey um i'm gonna like
hang over
my toes over an actual skyscraper
40 or 50 stories above fifth avenue with
no safety equipment
and you're just gonna like fill me over
my shoulder and it's gonna be fine um if
you had told me to do that i'd be like
yep i quit i quit honestly i wouldn't
even like have gone up there and looked
over the edge
because no
nope
nope yep
um not having it tila says yeah man
[ __ ]
yosemite is the freshest air [ __ ]
known to man hell yeah
and remember it'd be like in the morning
where it's like 30 degrees fahrenheit 40
degrees fahrenheit you breathe in with
your nose you come out of sleeping bag
you breathe it in and you just feel it
just kind of like burning cold up in
your nose
and that [ __ ]
yosemite is like air production facility
of the [ __ ] world you can tell the
air is being made there from out of
those trees
gigantic redwoods you'd [ __ ] love it
those [ __ ] trees are [ __ ]
huge huge diameter trees and they're
[ __ ] they're the size of a [ __ ]
10-story building at least i know i
don't know but probably big big trees
gigantic
and uh just a beautiful place man and it
feels prehistoric
and then the rivers are [ __ ] great
all the waterfalls and stuff and you can
swim in certain places and there's all
those damn warnings of hey don't drown
and all the [ __ ] trails you can go
yeah hey
back in the 70s and 80s when i used to
go there the don't hey don't drown signs
had [ __ ] pictures of dead people
floating in the damn water from drowning
yeah drowning that it stuck in my mind
like yeah don't drown uh [ __ ]
because uh you know and waterfalls and
[ __ ] and to be next to some of those
[ __ ] raging waterfalls you can stand
there and it's just
it's it's a river
60 foot wide and 30 foot deep going over
a damn
cliff
that's about 60 feet and the sound is
just
you can feel it vibrating you through
the air just the shock wave and that
damn waterfall and you're looking at it
you're just you're a kid and you're just
[ __ ] overwhelmed you know even
overwhelming adult you're like god damn
the power
you know of nature and people were doing
weird [ __ ] like getting in boats and
going over that [ __ ]
you know which was dangerous as [ __ ]
that's why they were saying don't don't
drown
yeah they're getting a [ __ ] rubber
raft and [ __ ] try to go over that
damn waterfall honestly if you want to
do that stuff um i kind of feel like
that's uh
self selection well what happens is they
a lot of times they go over that
waterfall and they get sucked under and
they're down there for a long time and
then the [ __ ] raft comes up and
they're [ __ ] with their panels and
[ __ ]
did you learn did they learn
they would do it again this is
california they didn't those [ __ ] are
crazy yeah yeah they're crazy well it's
part of their sport
but no the waterfall will hold them
under there and everything's lashed
inside the boat or the kayak sometimes
it's a kayak
and it comes back up to the surface
eventually but they were like under
there for a long time at least it seemed
to me when i was a kid i was like oh man
he drowned he's not coming out and then
boom and then the boat comes up and he
starts paddling he's shaking it off
[ __ ] i'm stuck yeah yeah oh
damn
that is [ __ ] up yeah
as soy infused as a lot of californians
are they got some [ __ ] badass
californians that do [ __ ] like that
they're [ __ ] crazy
mountain climbers and people that go
down oh yeah white water rafting and
stuff and uh
not everything they do is kosher like
they were doing that in areas where and
when i was going there as a kid they
were doing what they were doing white
water rafting in places where the
rangers said you couldn't do it
because it was too dangerous and that's
like a challenge to them okay we're
gonna do it
they're like oh well that sounds like
the fun part yeah yeah
i don't know if it's still like that t
would probably know she still lives down
there
oh i'm sure there's places [ __ ] doing
that yeah and they were doing [ __ ] like
smuggling hang gliders up on [ __ ] in
places in yosemite where they weren't
supposed to and hang gliding off of
[ __ ] famous rocks like that half dome
that she's talking about it's this huge
[ __ ] it looks like a half round thing
with the front of it broken off and on
the trees it's amazing it just looks
prehistoric it looks like it looks like
something impossible they had dudes
smuggling hang gliders up there and
[ __ ] jumping off of it with a hand
glider they weren't supposed to be doing
that either
i don't know if they are still doing it
but they would do anything oh i'm sure
there yeah mr roboto says uh am i in
time for the naked shot glass
you weren't but i will show it again
just for you
bee's nest
sent us the shot glass
i'm like reluctant to put it too close
to the camera because i don't know if
like youtube is gonna like [ __ ] but
look we got some like agave leaves there
and also
look there's a little mexican man
on here and um
that's like a little like that's his
little butt and that's his little dick
and balls
i'm putting it way back here because i
don't if i put it too close to the
camera i kind of feel like it'll be like
flagging this part he's talking about
how good that water tastes coming out
yeah that water was the best water in
all of mankind was the water coming down
out of the out of those mountains it was
uh tasted like it was ice cold
ice cold and it was just [ __ ] clear
[ __ ] most beautiful water ever t you
would trip the [ __ ] out in the 70s and
the 80s
it was a different scene man the [ __ ]
rangers were all had weed and they would
give it out it took cute girls and my
ants were cute so they would get all
this weed
we were drinking [ __ ] any green
springs wine and mixing it with [ __ ]
seven up to make the prototype [ __ ]
wine coolers just like zima yeah and you
were walking around and [ __ ] there
was all kinds of nudism going on nude
teenage girls and [ __ ] [ __ ] walking
around and we had bikers like with
choppers and [ __ ] up there
[ __ ] run around naked with their
girlfriends and [ __ ] doing things in
campfires it was just a different scene
back then i don't know if it's like that
now but i heard it's not heard has
changed according to my eye
it's not as good as it was
but it was just a different scene back
then and there wasn't weren't as many
people
and you could get away with a lot more
and it was just 70s
california [ __ ] kind of like
naturistic [ __ ] return to nature kind
of hedonism in a certain way it was good
animalism
it was nice
nice might have formed some of my
[ __ ] earlier behavior and i was
growing up in a military academy at this
time so i had these weird mixtures of
christian military academy and then
going out into the wild and maybe that
just kind of
gave me my uh
my my [ __ ] appreciation of [ __ ]
living outside and not really liking
civilization all that much all the time
you know
i like a mixture
yeah i got that i hear that damn call of
the wild sometimes oh my god
just [ __ ] sleep outside
go catch some [ __ ] rainbow trout
okay yeah
you can do that whenever you want to
yeah
no one's stopping
you guys says that shot glass is
hilarious
it is
uh you know in case you guys didn't uh
notice like i said i'm not i'm reluctant
to put it too close to the camera
because i don't know if youtube's gonna
flag it
because look
from far away
it's a little butt
little yeah digging balls he is funny um
so the whole thing is that you're
supposed to put like a shot glass in it
there's shackles in here
and when you drink it you're gonna put
your nose like right in this dude's
taint
is
kind of the idea so i got it i got it
it's just kind of like
when i because i grew up in daytona
beach
and uh
there was a shop on the beachfront
and they did a brisk business in
titty-shaped
coffee mugs
you know yeah coffee mug shaped like
pair of tits
and they sold a lot of this so this is
kind of like the same kind of thing
tammy's asking too that she's ever been
to alaska yeah alaska would be the
closest thing to california alaska and
county and um i would actually i would
have a lot of nice [ __ ] up alaska and
then uh mr roboto is asking us me if
we've ever gone to these nudist things
here in florida there's a lot of that
now i got there's some uh there's this
girl on my [ __ ] uh friends list well
there's a there's a beach called playa
linda linda
she runs that [ __ ] which is a very
famous nudist speech in florida i've
never been there though they got some
chick that's on my friend's list who's
like this [ __ ] goth chick with
[ __ ]
dreads and stuff and she's constantly
promoting
uh
this nudist resorts around here but if
you if you see what's going on there
nowadays
it's nothing like it was back in the 70s
because in the 70s it wasn't really
contrived
and it was out in nature
it was uh so if
when you
the dudes that are doing that now here
they're like these [ __ ] kind of
hippie dudes and it's just
not really our scene and
them damn a lot of them are ugly people
back in california in the 70s no they
were [ __ ]
top notch every good looking people well
everybody
yeah they were taking their clothes off
[ __ ] yeah and it was just people of
all ages and it's and it really wasn't a
sexual thing it was just uh
um
it was just like people trying to escape
[ __ ] civilization you know returning
to the wild what it's like or at least
pretending to be so
it's a different time
different time it's not quite the same
now
yeah that's true
i kind of feel like considered corny
nowadays
yeah because i kind of feel like the
most of the nudist scene nowadays yeah
let's
not uh put to find a point on it
is mostly like kind of like middle-aged
people that are maybe and nobody would
want to see naked probably danny danny's
asked us what our favorite slasher
movies are
ooh slasher movies
um favorite slasher movies hmm
i know what mine is what's yours
uh
it's um
friday the 13th part two
that's a good one yeah part two not one
but two
honestly yeah that's a really good one
i'm going to go back like earlier i'm
going to say maybe black christmas or
even prior to that maybe
bay of blood aka twitch of the death
nerve
uh which arguably first slasher movie
i don't know i it's not my favorite sub
genre but i do like a lot of them i do
like a lot of them
i don't know
yeah
um
i'm trying to what was that one that i
saw oh the prowler was pretty good
prowler
that's a good slasher movie
tina's talking about going on those
cruises and she likes the privacy
balconies where she can get out there
and wrap up
her and her husband look at the hubby
and look at them glaciers
she's
of course you're married to a glacier
glider
like a vanilla gorilla a vanilla gorilla
of glacier
glacier
glen
glacier glider yeah that's when you're
gliding across the glacier
sure
one of honky kongs
i wasn't expecting you to stop talking
no i just stopped as always
it seemed like you were going to like
carry on i thought i was going to
continue rambling
yeah that's what you usually do so i i
was just expecting
she's expecting more entertainment well
no i never to stop talking because you
always he doesn't like you're always
talking i'm gonna stop talking so i
never expect you to stop talking
uh tila says tammy says we went on
princess cruises never again lol
uh we got the private balcony nice
giraffe him ribs yeah i honestly i'm not
a big
if i had the money which i don't uh but
if i had the money to actually go on a
vacation
i honestly
not a big fan of like the cruise [ __ ]
i get it like i get that we're on a boat
and we can go
here there the other place and there's
like buffets
and you have a room and you don't have
to like
move from place to place like i get the
appeal of it
but
i don't know man
in another way i never got the appeal of
it louie showed up what's up louie
one i don't want to be on the [ __ ]
ocean because sharks
um
and
other things
but
i don't know i don't i don't love i
don't love the idea of just like being
on a ship
you know what i'm not mystified i mean i
don't get seasick i don't nothing like
that but it's just kind of like i don't
know i don't love it i i get the appeal
of it but i don't
that's not really anything that i ever
wanted to do yeah i'm not a big cruise
person
but i can understand why people would
want to do it
uh i understand the appeal of it
to us is tom polar bear
yeah i'm like the abdominal snowman the
abdominal flamin yeah i'm not as
abdominal as i used to be i've lost a
bunch of weight
you told that story right i don't think
so have you told that story should you
tell the story all right
[Laughter]
he might have told the story before i'm
not i don't remember
our friend dimitri and his wife
um
jen and me and jenny
went to uh tampa
to do a show that we had going on down
there
and he was spinning
we just stayed the same vampire ball
vampire ball that's right that was a
couple years back yeah
maybe i should show these people to to
give context and everything but anyway
they were in the bed next to us we were
you know we had two
we had we were in the same house in the
same hotel room and it had a living room
and it was a big hotel room but there
were two
king-sized beds
were they king-sized i think they were
or queen-sized or something they were
[ __ ] big
and we were in our bed and they were in
their bed and this was at the end of the
night we were [ __ ] drunk as [ __ ] man
we were really drunk yeah but fun drunk
not like i can't remember what happened
the next stage it was and it's just fun
dimitri keeps [ __ ] with me he's
trying to get me to do something what
was he trying he was he was
i can't remember what he was doing but
he's messing around with
with his wife
and i messed around with my girlfriend
here jenny and i [ __ ] bucked up on
her and [ __ ] [ __ ] like that i with it
like that
and jay's like started laughing it's
just what are you that says i'm the
abdominal snowman
[ __ ] those two started [ __ ]
busting up laughing i did as well
and i never lived it down
the abdomen to this day this is like
three or four years ago to this day yeah
you still get healthy yeah he said you
go do it again tom
yeah
they're good people
that was a fun night yeah it was fun i
mean that was a fun night yeah
yeah that was bad there was all kinds of
[ __ ] in dimitri's mind too that you know
he
he he wanted this to be like a [ __ ]
nevermind
[Laughter]
but you know
oh goodness he wanted me to be getting
it and he wanted to get me and him like
high-fiving across the [ __ ] beds of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you know you want you
know he wanted you guys to be talking to
each other and [ __ ] while i was going
down and you know it was is all it was a
fantasy in his mind and then he wanted
to like take some pictures and [ __ ] it's
like they do the giggity cell phone it
didn't unfold that way though
see
it would have been beautiful it would
have been we were all entirely too drunk
yeah looking um
uh but both jen and jenny were looking
beautiful that night
and um they both look like models and
[ __ ] i'm going to show you guys jen
i think i had a picture of both of you
together don't i
we probably do from that although we're
red or red or red yeah a red
oh okay we're back
we're back
we're back
that's that's what we're talking about
do you get a face i can't get a face on
that look
i might have some pictures of you guys
you probably have one from that night
like i said that was a long time ago
yeah
that was really fun though yeah
we went the year or two after that and
then like i drank too much and got sick
and like barfed on myself so it wasn't
as fun
the second time but
first time it was super fun
trying to see
yeah tillis is a little hiccup but now
yeah i can see you i see when it goes
there's jen when she's off and dressed
up with her boobs and [ __ ] that's just a
couple weeks back actually
with my favorite wig yeah
my favorite wig
no i don't have a picture of you guys
i thought i
i thought we had like a lot of pictures
from that night but like i said that was
a long time ago yeah that was like three
or four years ago
that's jen and
that's our friend laura and laura
yeah laura has the same name as me
that's laura ross even though we're not
related
yeah
laura's awesome we haven't seen her in a
while
well she always says she's going to come
out and then she doesn't come out
so yeah yeah
there's jen is so sonia that's when jim
was a redhead
look how cute they were
yeah back when i was cute yeah it's not
like nowadays well i'm just saying no
you're cute right there
she's oh you're taking [ __ ] [ __ ]
funny way
that was cute red hair though
well that was kind of like the red that
i had that was only a couple years ago
yeah it was only a couple years yeah
black's easier
yeah
i mean
i don't know you've got i don't know if
you guys know my like my hair is
naturally red
but
it's just easier to do black it's just
it covers
you know you get some gray roots you can
just like
comb some black over it wash it out it's
you know
but my hair is red actually
so
i mean that
obviously is not my natural color that
was like a darker red than i did but
oh it's red again oh okay
yeah it's back okay working is tom diana
ross ah there's no telling oh there's a
lot of rosses in the south and there uh
there are white rosses and black rosses
but that is not a plantation name that
is a free man's name and it's because
like i told you guys before on early
earlier shows
in mississippi in alabama even during
slave days
there were of course
free black people and they lived right
alongside
free white share croppers and there was
lots of interbreeding between the two
segregation which happened a lot later
was an attempt to try to reverse
the interbreeding between the two so
it's not all what they try to tell you
it is okay
that the no there are white rosters and
black and white rosters and black rosses
in there but there were no ross
plantations
tila says jen looks good with red hair
yeah
yeah that's
like i said that's my natural hair color
and honestly if it wasn't so much of a
pain in the ass
i would just have bright red hair all
the time but
i had bright red hair for how long did i
have that
i mean my natural hair
is my natural hair is like an orangey
coppery red that's what my natural hair
color is it's probably great at this
point i don't really know because i'm
old
but
for a time i had this really really
bright
red hair
and i loved it
but
honestly you had a comb die through it
every
week
yeah and it left
don't wash it and it left like it
stained all the sheets everything stay
in the sheets the pillowcases stay in
the shower tiles um so it was like a big
[ __ ] nightmare i loved it but
man
what a pain in the ass that's why i went
back to black because i was just kind of
like
look
i like red more but
black is better it just covers
everything like i said black most of
this stuff in the back which is actual
my hair
will stay black
every now and then i just comb black
through the roots
and the bangs
where it grows out right here
and
then i just wash it out and it's fine
the red
um i had to bleach it first
because you know my hair been black for
so long so i had to bleach it out
and then
um i had to dye it and then you had to
pretty much comb the red dye
through the hair
once a week
if you didn't do that it would turn this
weird
kool-aid pink color
which i wasn't a fan of so
if you want to have your hair that's
what i mean like if you want to have
your hair like these bright colors
you really got to keep on top of that
stuff you got to like
maintain it
and i don't
have the patience for it
i love the look of the red
but i don't have the patience
to maintain it
and also like i said it stained
everything in our old bathroom
everything in our old bathroom
had red
dye like all [ __ ] over it all over it
because i had to do it once a week or it
would just like fade
black stays longer i have to do the
roots but i only have to do the roots
you know once every
three or four weeks so it's not it's not
too bad
bread i had to do it
every week and i had to like not wash it
you know what i'm saying
because it would like wash out
uh ooh
come on come on come on come on
come on
there we go
uh tila says black is beautiful jenna
looks awesome on you thank you um
yeah
honestly like i said it's not the ideal
situation i would love to have like
[ __ ] honestly i would like to like
bright red or purple or something like
that but it's just it's too much trouble
to maintain it
black is much much easier
much easier it covers everything
you don't worry about bleaching it um
you know
it's much easier
all right so uh tila says ladies y'all
can always put on a wig the natural
account it costs a lot but saves you
real and honestly i've got to a point
where
look i'm just going to keep the [ __ ]
black and if i want a different color
hair i'm just going to slap a wig over
the [ __ ]
because
dye in the shade of color it's just it's
too much trouble
yeah i like the way it look i loved the
bright red i loved it
but [ __ ] man
too much trouble
[ __ ] too much ecological damage
well not it
like the whole [ __ ] inside of the
shower like everything like in the shot
of the shower was like dyed red
the pillowcases were tied red
it's just kind of like i had to bleach
the hair out and it was like dried out
so i had to like put like [ __ ]
conditioner in it it looked awesome but
you had to [ __ ]
the thing about like bright colors like
that is that i don't i don't know if
people realize but you have to like
you have to comb die through it like
every week
or it's not going to maintain that bra
it fades very very quickly especially
red straw dog says that jenny that
little orphan annie wig on you was a
good look i don't know what the little
orphan eddie wait
did i wear it did i wear the did i wear
the weird um your weird
uh michael caine wig or yeah
that was not a that was not a wig that
red hair that was her real hair
well my yes my natural hair is red yeah
my natural hair is red
i'm a redhead
yeah um
but
as long as we've been doing the show i
don't think about a redhead the whole
time but but i'm naturally a redhead but
it but it might be like gray at this
point i don't really know we haven't
seen it in a long time i haven't seen in
a long time
what are these all grown out you're
probably not great
you're probably not great i don't know
like my mom was gray by the time she was
this age so
i don't know maybe maybe
mr roboto says let my ginger roots shine
like i said
it's probably all gray at this point i
don't think it's grey
but
honestly when i was younger i i might
have some picture somewhere but i don't
know where they are
when i was younger
my hair was like is is a was a beautiful
i don't i didn't appreciate it at the
time obviously but now i do in
retrospect
my hair was like a beautiful
copper penny
red
orange
my hair was like orange
naturally
yeah is what color my hair was
uh you know just a beautiful copper
color
um but you know we'll see you around
louie i didn't love it at the time
tina's gonna go oh it's tina tina's
gotta take off
danny ghostface asks what are
what's our opinion on the paranormal
activity films uh the first one was good
the
sequels that i saw i didn't love them i
didn't love the first one either
but
the first one was actually good it was
like actually really creepy
um
i haven't seen all the sequels i saw the
second one and the third i've only seen
the first one i don't remember much
about it
it was pretty good though i remember the
first one being all right yeah if you
like found footage it's like it's
actually really good that was kind of
creepy that was the problem i didn't
think it's great because i i don't like
fan footage
i don't either but yeah
if something's gonna be
i really gotta go back and see the
original final footage with the blair
witch product project i've never seen it
you have never seen the blair witch
project never seen it
i think that might be on hulu never seen
it
well the original found footage is
actually cannibal holocaust yeah okay
and we've seen that yeah i guess uh um
that's the first one the first one i
remembered that was a big hit and
[ __ ] that was the first one that like
uh took the concept to mainstream let's
see
back in the late 90s all the little goth
girls i was hanging out with my first
wife and she was like it was good they
were like haven't you seen
tom haven't you seen black women's
project and i'm like no i haven't seen
that man what the hell is wrong with you
we got to go to the theater to see blair
witch project because it was still in
the movies at that time
and i was like yeah yeah i'll go see if
i never got around to it
yeah
i can't believe you know that's melissa
it was upset that i didn't see the blair
witch project
you missed out on like so much cultural
[ __ ] that came out back then
well it's just kind of like yeah well
the thing about it though is that
i kind of feel like i saw a blair witch
project in the theater
and i knew that it wasn't real
but
the thing about the blair witch project
that was [ __ ] genius about it
was that i mean it's a good movie but
the marketing was the brilliant thing
because they marketed it
like it was really
i mean the actors that were in it
they're like hey
um you guys just like [ __ ] keep on
the dl yeah like while this movie's so
we can pretend that you're actually
really missing so they really they
committed yeah they had a website about
the [ __ ] lore about the [ __ ] so it
was like a [ __ ] genius bit of
marketing like before that was really a
thing yeah
um so
now that it was cutting edge marketing
oh yeah big time big time yeah straw
dogs um uh i have alpha justice i've
seen it i just don't remember it
you got to remind me which one is that
i have out for justice
i have
under siege one and two and i have hard
to kill
and i have
is alfred justin's the one where he's
the cop with the wearing the ramp damn
black beret
all right i think that's the one okay
but like is that the only one where that
happened
what
where he had a black no he only has the
blackberry
really yeah i want to see the one where
he [ __ ] goes up there and fights for
the eskimos and blows up the damn
blows up the [ __ ] oil rigs i want to
see that one because they say that one's
terrible they say it's terrible it's
like i know what you're talking about
i've seen that one it's supposed to be
his last hollywood movie
pretty much
and they're like
[ __ ] you gotta go
but they were kind of like
evidently the director and the people
who were involved in it were kind of
like undermining him they couldn't stand
him because he had pissed them off
during the deer during production
and
and they're like we're going to make
sure this movie [ __ ] bombs
get this [ __ ] out of here well you
know that's what happens when you're an
insufferable douche yeah and he was like
[ __ ]
he was waxing all green
you know trying to be green as [ __ ]
[ __ ] environmental protectionist and
then he's a [ __ ] douche come on
which is weird because
that's not in his repertoire
it's really not no i mean because
considering like how the the movies that
he made later
yeah um
not really the same deal at all so he
was he was trying to come up he was
trying to uh sell himself off as like a
real zen master of on deadly ground
somebody said yeah the ground
i want to say thank you thank you
that was it uh i want to see that one i
just don't know if i want to pay for
that one no don't pay please don't pay
for it
i couldn't live with myself
and then i want to see that one but uh
he evidently was just constantly trying
to like
like he he was on one of those movies at
the drop of a hat he goes nah i'm not
gonna kill anybody
like we talking about i can't kill
anybody in these movies because it goes
against
what my zen master [ __ ] said you know
this is not the way of [ __ ] aikido or
not akita what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
that he that he he is you know versus
diverted that we can't kill anybody and
they're like man this is a [ __ ] movie
we're not really killing people you're
leaving you gotta kill the bad guy at
the very end you know it's percent no no
i'm not gonna do it but evidently they
they [ __ ] edited it and they edited
it in a way to where it made he ended up
killing him anyway
by edit
[Laughter]
dead but it's death death
yeah or it was the worst kind of death i
think they said that it might have been
kind of what he called
up in the air whether or not he actually
died but most people would seeing it
would believe that no no he got killed
you know what i mean there might have
been something we're being already we're
leaving an ambiguous they were kid
i don't remember which movie that was
but um
i mean
i'm not a [ __ ] steven seagal expert
i'm a steven seagal observer all right
i saw what i saw
i saw what i saw and understood what i
saw and that was enough i don't and
every time i see
his movies come up
his newer [ __ ] is horrible and what
makes it horrible is this [ __ ] boring
really [ __ ] boring they're just
unwatchable
and i think it's just amazing that he
has made a career on making movies that
are just
boring and unwatchable it's a
well it's a terrible combination of
boring and
uh being totally up one's own ass yeah
edited so he's got [ __ ] stunt doubles
that walk up and down the stairs for him
so because they can't see how fat he is
just
all kinds of [ __ ] it's amazing and he
moves to russia and has like a million
kids with like four different women and
and and they're all hot and how did he
pull this [ __ ] off
just and the whole and then hey i'll
give you ten thousand dollars if you
have a baby for me i don't know um okay
i just think maybe you know i'd rather
not but okay these russian eastern
european women don't really understand
what seagal's all about they go yeah
he's famous and then somehow that that
that mystifies them and the next thing
you know they're well yeah that's the
thing maybe they don't maybe they don't
have the same cultural context they're
like oh well he's famous in america okay
yeah it's exactly right they don't have
the cultural context until it's too late
yeah because like in the u.s everybody's
like yeah no no not that dude no no
i'll just stay and then the whole asian
experience commercial you can find that
commercial on youtube asian experience
you guys can look at
what the [ __ ] like the asian chicken
the [ __ ] why cool i know baby oh i'm
gonna come see you baby you ready the
the drinking the energy drink
sorry like sorry my vagina just dried up
they got people that they got cobwebs
came across it it was just it was a
whole thing they have steven seagal
collectors
i know they collect that [ __ ] and and i
know and that
drink if you can find a can an unopened
can of asian experience it's worth
hundreds of dollars
it's amazing when you think well they
did that whole [ __ ] on uh what yeah
what's that channel what's that general
like
i don't remember
[ __ ]
uh
i don't know i can't think there was a
channel out there that covered it yeah
yeah
that's just amazing amazing to me
but it was another time and looking back
on and i now understand how it happened
well he happened the same way black belt
magazine happened
when you don't have the internet you can
get away with a lot of [ __ ] well and the
thing about it nowadays is that
everybody's going to like it nowadays is
going to like it like ironically
well that's that's his fans i think a
lot of his fans are like everybody's
like although nobody likes the [ __ ] i
run it although i must i must confess
back in the day i've made comments on
youtube calling [ __ ] on [ __ ]
seagull
and was attacked by his fans
who on youtube remember back when the
comment section actually actually worked
and you got notifications when somebody
responded to you which that doesn't
happen anymore
what i still do where where are you from
i don't get
i get one out of ten responses one out
of ten i'll get a notification i get an
email every time somebody like responds
to one of my you must have like a good
profile you must have a good reputation
or something on youtube i
i only get the very first notification
to any response i still get it and i
never get in notifications after that um
i'm probably shadow band
um so anyway the the the the [ __ ]
what was i saying
oh i got attacked by his [ __ ] fans
who
ardently believe in everything that
steven seagal says that's so cute yeah
they just oh no he's he's a great man
oh no he he's a [ __ ] master martial
artist
that could probably beat us on
chuck norris and mike tyson at the same
time at the same time yeah
and godzilla and godzilla
and oh no he's and cthulhu and he is and
he's a master musician and everybody
loves his music which he's actually a
better musician than he is an actor i
gotta say that which is not saying much
he could play he could play good he
plays good but he's um punati song oh
she was ridiculous but but he was
playing i'm not saying the the con you
know what i mean
i'm not saying the content of his music
a lot of people can play instruments
yeah he can play an instrument
but he can't act he can play an
instrument but he can't act
not not really yeah obviously all of his
movies have him tubbed
somebody else is doing his voice that's
amazing you said tubbed dubbed
although tubbed is awesome
too i said that that's also no you said
tubbed yeah but
that's also relevant
[Laughter]
maybe that that's what you were thinking
of right
because he's like
i'm not hating i'm not fat jamie louie
says you gotta remember that seagull was
one of the biggest action movie stars of
late
80s and early 90s yes he was he was it
was only it was for like five minutes no
it wasn't five minutes it was about
three or four well i'm engaging in
hyperbole which is a form of humor i
remember it louie i was there i bought
into it so was i i bought into the hype
i'm like
i did not
yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah i was putting him up
there with like yeah like steven seagal
or
well not steve skull
it's kind of like uh what i was going to
say like um
[ __ ] what are you trying to do
and like those guys jean claude john
club or jean-claude yeah although i
think darn i think i think uh
jean-claude is
a bit of a
bit of a [ __ ] fake himself even
though physically he was a lot a lot
more
uh
well he was in much better shape yeah
he's a lot more capable um
he could act a little bit
sort of
he had some good movies i really liked
universal soldier the first one i mean
uh
the rest you really have to kind of like
uh you know as far as action stars go
you have to kind of like give them a
little bit of
leeway yeah as far as acting ability and
and you know we're not talking about a
sylvester stallone level
actor with cigar nowhere near
stallone can act
oh yeah and he can write yeah okay he's
very well like i said i'm i'm never
gonna [ __ ] on sylvester stallone because
he's talented yeah he's multi-talented
yeah he can do like the bodybuilding
thing but he's also like a writer he's
also an actor and like he's been in like
some good [ __ ] so right
and that motherfucker's alpha as [ __ ]
he's he's real good
and and he's better than [ __ ] arnie
by far even though i liked a lot of
arnie's movies especially the early ones
but really still overall stallone was
the [ __ ] the best out of all that all
those guys well he's more versatile yeah
he comes across more like a real person
arne doesn't come across like a person
no
um in the sense that he just comes
across an archetype yeah
more than like an actual human
yeah he had some good movies
but
but there are arnold schwarzenegger
movies
and yes there's there he's just that
that's what he does
which you know like i said that's that's
fair stallone could show up and you
don't know what the hell is going to
happen right pulls it off yeah i mean he
like i said he's more like a a writer
and actor
arnold schwarzenegger is just arnold
schwarzenegger well here's the thing
arnold was a bodybuilder that made it as
an actor
stallone was an actor that ended up
making it as a bodybuilder
that there's a big difference
and you know and yeah he went to gold's
gym and started having the right
trainers and [ __ ] and he got
as built as those guys but he had other
[ __ ] going on he started off as an actor
and a [ __ ] right
so he had a a bunch of other like
ballots prior to that
he didn't come into it yeah from that he
came into it from he saw what arnold did
says i could do that i was gonna go into
gold's gym and [ __ ] you know me and
dave zane me and frank zane it's like
frank zane trained it if i remember
correctly
he was a good trainer and he was another
[ __ ] bodybuilder
um you know about the size of [ __ ]
arnold
and you know they all hung out in this
[ __ ] gold's gym down there in muscle
beach
for a while
i'm glad that [ __ ] stallone didn't go
that crazy with the size
he just for rambo three he got [ __ ]
stacked
and the same for [ __ ] judge dredd and
some of the other movies and he stayed
in good shape
a lot of people won't believe this but
[ __ ]
stallone's best movie for me in terms of
like depth and story
and lessons to learn was actually um
demolition man
demolition man was [ __ ] the best one
although you haven't seen cop land
haven't seen copland yet you should
probably see i'll check it out
it's really good i saw it in the theater
actually it's really good
you should probably see yeah
you should probably see
it's getting late i'm getting hungry
yeah i'm kind of hungry too yeah we'll
get some tell you
all right so
what do we have any other uh questions
that we have to answer uh i don't think
so probably not man i gotta drive to
ocala tomorrow yeah
i'm gonna try and get some sleep yeah
well it's 9 30 we need if you want to
get something to eat we should [ __ ]
move now we should go ahead and i'll
start on it for you all right so we
should probably get some food all right
so thanks everybody for dropping by this
friday evening i'm gonna finish up my
drink we're gonna get something to eat
i'm gonna go to sleep because i gotta
drive to [ __ ] ocala tomorrow i'm
gonna see my mom
which would be cool because i'm seeing a
really long time
so thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for your super chats we'll be
back on probably sunday
talking about some movie or whatever
uh as we usually do
thanks for hanging in there with us
with all our
[ __ ] connection issues
um so we'll see you guys on sunday
afternoon
uh good night have a good weekend bye